I'm a bit of a romantic
so to me even your Einstein book yeah
had lessons on on romance and
relationships oh yeah
so how important are romantic
relationships to the success of Great
Men great women great minds
well sometimes people who affect the
course of humanity
have better relationships with Humanity
than they do with the humans sitting
around them Einstein
had two interesting relationships with
wives That's what you know maleva his
first wife was a sounding board and help
with the mathematics of the special
relativity paper in particular
um but he didn't treat it well I mean he
uh made her like sign a letter that she
wouldn't interrupt him she wouldn't you
know and finally when she wanted a
divorce he couldn't afford it because he
was still a patent Clerk
and so uh he offered her a deal which is
I think totally amazing he said one of
these days one of those papers from 1905
is going to win the Nobel Prize
if we get a divorce
uh you know I'll give you the money
um that was a lot of money back then
like a million dollars now or something
and she's smart she's a scientist she
consults with a few other scientists and
after a week or so she takes the bat is
that until what 1919 that he wins his
Nobel Prize
uh and
she gets all the money she buys three
apartment buildings in Zurich uh with
his second wife Elsa it was more a
partnership of convenience it was not a
romantic love but he knew and that
sometimes what people need in life is
just a partner I mean somebody who's
going to handle the stuff you're not
going to handle
so I guess if you look at my books
they're not great inspiring guides to
personal relationships